our next guest is a huge University of
South Carolina fan a big Dolphins fan
okay and you may know him from his
appearance as a cowboy in that Burger
King commercial or his brilliant music
career that spanned over 30 years even
though you didn't see him in the CNN
special about great music in the 1990s
[Music]
I'm so bad
at the parish party Darius
okay so we're at the pairings party on
Tuesday night Darius is getting one of
the the great awards you can get the
Arnold Palmer award all of his charity
work that he's done with golf so he one
of the first things he says to me he
goes hey you see that CNN music special
1990 no they didn't include us in the
special on great music from the 90s
[Laughter]
because I go up to Darius and I said you
know imagine dragons are sort of the
foodie and the Blowfish now this is
where he's gonna tell you I'm glad you
don't remember you were vicious to me
like I didn't I know but I I was being
serious about because I said it you know
people got to the point where they're
like hey we're mad that we we bought the
album of hooting the Blowfish absolutely
and now the thing with imagine dragons
is they're still I they're taking the
gigs because they don't have the money
you go on tour you do things and and
they're you know too big too fast well
that's it some of the things we get too
big too fast and and people love to hate
you and you know you just go through
that and you hope you sit there 25 years
later you know going I did all right but
country they stick with you yeah country
fans of like they're okay if you like
burst onto the scene yeah they like I
always I always say country fans the pop
fans always want them to what what's
next what's the next big thing and
country fans want the next big thing but
they also want that that blanket that
they've been you know that have had on
their bed the last 10 years they still
want to hear that too so yeah I love
that so what was the line I had I don't
remember come on no was it really that
mean
[Laughter]
did you guys remember anything that I
would have said after no just me and you
standing there Oh was yeah but you came
and that was very nice I know I I said
that I wanted to be out early I wanted
to come in because it you know what
we've been friends for now coming up 25
years yes 25 and you're now a pga
ambassador yes I'm uh what does that
mean that means I you play anywhere you
want do funny that you say that you know
it is part of my deal that I could play
all the TPC courses and and I got a list
of my tour the other day and all the TPC
courses close but are you like sir Nick
Faldo are you like ambassador Rucker
like wow oh I didn't even think about
that I got three honorary doctorates and
I'm an ambassador so yes I think I
should be ambassador Rucker yes you can
have to call me that
well there's three letters an ambassador
that I would call you so the Arnold
Palmer oh yeah I'm so proud of that yes
yeah and you you'd met Arnie Arnie I had
become friends we had hung out I got to
go play golf with oh I got good I went
to Pittsburgh with him I mean I you know
I went down and played golf with him in
Florida a few times weird and you're
like come on every time I hung out with
him he wouldn't let me call him mr.
Palmer and you know I'm southern and
that's just hard for me yeah but he
wouldn't let me call mr. parmitt he
always made me call him Arnie and you
know we'd be sitting there and he'd be
I'm sitting there you know in Latrobe or
something and he's telling the joke and
I'm just like I'm sitting next to
frigging you might have been saying I'm
sitting next to Darius Rucker no you
like why who did you have that
experience with as a musician where you
go holy smokes
oh one of my bucket list things was to
meet McCartney and so I got to go to a
show and I got to meet him before the
show and I'm with my kids my wife and
we're there and he walks out of the back
and I'm telling you it was all I could
do not to cry it was all I could do not
to
right and he walks over and he talk we
start talking he's great he's he's so
paul he's so nice and everything and
it's great my daughter I love her so
much she's look though he said dad are
you about to cry but yeah mccartney
really shook me up but you didn't ask
for a picture did you know we that we
were there to take a picture okay did
you ask music questions no I just talked
about music I don't really get really
geeky cuz he was about to go on like
it's weird
never chris farley on Saturday Night
Live when he was like you remember when
you were with the Beatles it was awesome
and what do you say things I could say
but you know I just all I said was thank
you cuz he's part of the reason I'm
what's the song you wish that you wrote
let the Beatles row Oh
Hey Jude yeah perfect song really yeah
the perfect song have you ever covered
that got really lucky but that one's
perfect but you guys started out as a
cover band yeah what was your what was
your go to this is gonna slay this
brings the house down
dude there was a moment in our career
when we early on like this was year to
end in the plan where we played 12 REM
songs you do name-drop Mike Michael
Stipe a couple of times do we still REM
was everything for us everything but
then are you trying to emulate them when
you guys start like when you start to
write songs are you thinking how are em
what do this oh no we didn't do it not
that we you know we knew we couldn't
they were we thought they were the
greatest thing since the Beatles you
know and so we couldn't we just went out
and you know you played their songs and
then when we started out writing our
songs we just took it from everywhere
that we were you know from country and
all the stuff we listened to and came up
with our own thing who did you open up
for biggest name Wow goodness we open up
her a lot of the big names on one off
the Allman Brothers and we play with
them and we played with we played
festivals of stuff
those big you know oh we toured Europe
with Slash's Snakepit van Halen and oh
my god and Bon Jovi and we put playing
we were playing Rock am ring and rock
and we were playing the big you know
80,000 seat
places and it was unbelievable and we
have a great story about that we every
every time every time hoody plays before
we go on we toast and the last thing we
say is here is the slash and the reason
we say that as we were on that tour and
we had and we were playing rock and
wearing in Germany and uh we get our
trailers right back up the slashes and
got windows in the back and we're we're
about to go on and we look and we look
over in slashes over this trailer with
about 12 girls have you heard our meet
Friday songs yes I've heard you meet fry
this there's some pretty good meat
Fridays yeah I heard about that yeah I
wrote the meat fried a song for you
I did but you guys gonna have to help me
out okay yeah backing vocals you need do
you need headphones no I'm a
professional
I'll give you know you get so you you
did do a meet Friday so we got a funny
song okay now is this acapella don't do
an acapella right you want me to help
sing because the last thing I want you
to do I don't need this with a little
you've heard me do war yeah Ryder low
rye exactly we don't need that today
wait what's titled huh what's the title
hold my hand
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
there was food at the party and I said
hold my ham I'm sorry ladies and
gentlemen please welcome to the stage
Grammy award-winning country music star
three-time Grammy winner he'll be
singing wagon wheel the rest of his life
Hootie and the Blowfish May 30th in
Virginia Beach as they start their tour
here's Darius Rucker with a little dry
rub and some tenderness smoked a little
brisket but we won't make a mess that
way come on be a professional okay with
a little dry rub mmm and some tenderness
what's a little brisk AB but we won't
make a mess with a little salt and some
harmony together well because
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
because
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
this is work this is there's more work
yeah no no no
so the the reunion tour mm-hmm that that
means what 25 years since you guys broke
right
we broke 25 years ago yeah practive you
25 years unbelievable
I remember it like it was yesterday
unbelievable I mean but all of a sudden
you guys so it's one thing to put out an
album yes and then you hear like okay
wait there how many is it how many did
they buy and then all of a sudden it
becomes what eight eighth highest
selling album of all time
yeah that right yeah although CNN didn't
mention you in the 1992 unfollow Jake
Tapper how does that how does that
happen that CNN does something on music
from the 90s and you guys don't make it
that was really surprising to me to
think that cuz they did a big thing on
Nickelback didn't they
Thanks Nickelback got a full 20 all
right so the blow fit you guys are gonna
do a new album yeah yeah we're already
selling recording Rob we we've had our
first sessions and we're we're going
back in to finish it up soon it was fun
getting back together and doing it
and it's amazing how when the four of us
get together we fall exactly into that
same place we were years ago and you go
and do a time machine
time machine absolutely how long before
the first fight we we haven't had a
fight in 25 years we haven't had fight
in 30 years you guys never thought 100
Daltrey and Pete Townsend we were never
raised our voices to each other never I
never knew that that's we don't handle
things that way we're bad we both you
lose Gopal hmm any chance that hold my
ham makes the new out I'm cold I'm
physically calling my lawyer he's gonna
pay you in brisket well don't you have a
trigger girl yes I do
Chad my girl we got it right in our
tailgating we use it all the time a lot
who are you playing with today
Kenny Barry all right well he's a
country guy he's from Kentucky he is yes
my friends Kenny a long time you know
and who else you playing me uh Matt Ryan
I'm we've already got our game lined up
I'm gonna take some money from Matt yes
you know does he know that you big
Dolphins fan and you hate the Falcons I
don't hate the falcon haters reserved
for very special team who do you hate I
hate the Patriots I love Tom Brady how
do you love Brady and a little Billy
Jack to hate the Patriots wait the
concept of the Patriots you see when
your dolphin fan and you watch your team
lose every year you beat the Patriots
once and then they win the division and
go on to the Super Bowl
you can't not hate that to you my I hate
them because they're great I admit it I
hate them because they're great the tour
starts May 30th in Virginia Beach yes
and then you'll be coming I all catch
you a couple times there helps
[Laughter]
I'm still trying to survive 22 years ago
in Scotland and Ireland who I was
talking about that before the show that
was uh yeah I'm still trying to have
that because I wanted to take you guys
down I wanted well in London I did you
think you did some day the last day the
Woody Harrelson's story wood and fries
you remember oh I'm gonna take a break
before I get in trouble my wife's watch
love you honey if you want to see Derry
suit a couple shot by the way very good
golfer played with Bill Murray last year
and really really played well might be
lying about his handicap but that's for
another day and for other people to
worry about me today I love I love in
the throat no oh I wouldn't take away
your moneymaker for more Dan Patrick
show to the audience Channel 239 on
DirecTV or download the Dan Patrick show
app
[Music]